um David Waterman and so this
presentation is going to be about
writing tests for data science my
intended audience here is people who
probably have not written any tests or
they have written some tests but maybe
not necessarily for data science work
and so I'll do a little bit of
background about why you should test
your code to start I'll talk about the
reason that I came to this problem in
the first place why I decided that we
needed to start testing and then at the
end the last section will be about
actual practical implementation we'll
pull up some code and we'll write some
tests and look at them together so
before I get into like the actual
practice of writing tests I want to like
take a step back and think about why you
should bother writing tests and how to
think about them so I actually before I
was a data scientist I was a high school
math teacher for nine years so that's
kind of my go-to when I'm looking for
analogies so if you think about your
high school education it was probably
very similar to mine my math teachers
generally would give us homework
problems out of the textbook you know
they'd send you home with a page number
and a list of problems to do and a lot
of the times the answers to the problems
would be in the back of the book right
and so my big question that I actually
like somebody to respond to so just yell
out for me please is what's the point of
giving students homework problems if
you're going to give them the answers
that go with them to refine the process
of getting the answer right and anybody
else want someone over here to say
something
check yourself afterwards yep and so is
your teacher really trying to get you to
get the right answer if they're giving
you the answer to start with is that the
goal
and what does it mean to learn like why
would you bother going through all these
problems to learn what so you can figure
out how to solve equations right so you
can actually figure out the process to
get from the problem to the answer right
the answers are here to make sure that
you did the path correctly but the goal
is to have you practice getting from the
start to the finish all right and so if
you know where you're going you can
always tell if you're moving in the
right direction if you begin with the
end in mind you can make sure that as
you go through the steps you are moving
towards your goal right well many of our
daily tasks are like homework problems
right you have some kind of problem that
you're trying to solve and you know in
your head how it's going to look when
it's done you know the output that
you're expecting you know the results
that you want to see and you just need
to figure out how to write the code
that's going to get you to those correct
answers well if you start writing your
code with that mindset that's really
similar to the test-driven development
and so maybe we don't all necessarily
use this process intentionally but the
idea is that if you're going to do
test-driven development which is common
in software engineering you start by
writing a test for the code that you're
going to write before you code anything
and then you work on writing that code
and running the tests until you have a
passing test then you take a step back
and see if there's anything you can do
to refine what you've written you know
see if there's any refactoring
improvements that you can make and then
you move on to the next task and if you
break your problem down into small
bite-sized chunks you can just go
through the cycle over and over and over
again until you have what you need so
when we talk about testing our code you
know there's lots of reasons why we can
test our code for other people you know
the people who are going to be seeing
your code or your work the output that
you produce
having tested code is nice because it's
going to reduce your bugs it's going to
improve feedback loops so just going to
make it easier for you to see things
that you'd like to improve it's going to
speed up iteration make your code more
reusable and it's going to increase
other people's confidence in the system
that you've built for you it's going to
make other people trust you and your
work more because they're going to see
that you've already tested it out
beforehand it's going to earn you
respect from the people that you work
with if you work on a team with
developers engineers they have to do
this already it's not optional for them
right and so if you're doing the same
work and making the same contributions
that will get you more respect it allows
you to submit to open-source projects
you know most open-source projects they
won't let you add code without having it
tested as well and it's probably going
to be required to get your code accepted
into an external code base you know if
you are contributing code at work you
know there are lots of different ways
that data science is implemented in
different organizations but it seems
like the direction that people are
moving now is that we are moving from
siloed data science work where people
work independently on their own into
integrated data science work where data
scientists and software engineers and
project managers and testers and
everyone is all working in one group
together right and so if your
organization is moving in that direction
your code is going to start being looked
at by more people they're probably going
to want you to start contributing to the
same codebase as everyone else and tests
are probably going to be a requirement
for you in the future ok so that's why
we should test our code the reason that
I got to this problem in the first place
is because where I work we were trying
to do supply chain insight so basically
our customer buys big complicated things
and they know that when they buy it from
a vendor that vendor didn't make every
single part right there's a supply chain
behind it so I'm gonna use cars as my
example so when you buy a car you know
from Toyota Toyota didn't make the tire
they probably didn't make the brake pads
they didn't make the starter motor right
all of those were sourced from other
places and it's not just us a list of
suppliers it's a tree right so the brake
pads might have come from one direct
vendor but the transmission has bearings
in it those were probably purchased by
the transmission maker from somebody
else you know the bearings have metal in
them those bearing makers probably buy
their metal from somebody else and so to
figure out all the different companies
that are in that supply chain and all of
the different places where you have
weaknesses is really complicated
none of those companies want to share
that information surprisingly so what we
were working on is we were using news
articles we're just taking unstructured
text and processing it using natural
language processing and trying to
identify the relationships from those
news articles so if it says that Takata
is making airbags for Toyota that's what
we're trying to figure out now the
difficulty with that is that the stretch
structure of text is domain-specific
which means that regular people don't
talk the same way that you know
automotive news journalists would talk
about this issue so you can't use a
general text model to analyze this
information and really get the same
results that we want out you know if you
read the first example up here it says
for the long-term agreement webco will
supply its single piston air disc brake
technology max for the manufacturing of
Hyundai's new medium duty trucks where X
which are expected to start from August
2019 well that's not really the way that
most people talk it's not the way most
people write and so if you use a general
model you know if you just go on github
and find something to try to you know
pull out the useful information from
that sentence it's probably going to
fail so we've been trying to create our
own model that deals with this type of
text structure better but the problem is
that you know when we started out the
model was really bad we were getting
maybe 10 or 15% of the sense
that we were processing we're giving us
the output we were hoping for and so we
decided we needed some way to measure
and benchmark it so that as we worked on
the model we could see if it was
improving or not so our approach that we
used is called we're calling them gold
tests and we can humans can read the
text figure out the relationship from it
and then put it into a machine friendly
format like JSON or mo and then we can
write a test that's going to run our
data processing pipeline and compare it
to the manual test data and see if
there's a match up or not so a human
would write this example code on the
right and then we would load that up and
run a test and compare the test output
to this output ok so now let's actually
look at some code before I pull up my
repo I'm going to be using PI test as my
testing framework so there's a lot of
them that are out there PI test is one
of the most popular ones I like PI test
versus using the built-in unit test or
doc tests or nose or whatever for these
reasons it's more pythonic it's easy to
write there's less boilerplate you can
still run all of those different types
of tests so if you if you've already
written unit tests PI test will still
run them correctly and then it's got a
lot of nice add-on features like you can
generate HTML reports and it's got a
really great documentation set and
there's there's guides an example code
in the documentation that's really handy
the only downside is it's not a built-in
so you'll have to add it separately to
your requirements okay so for data
scientists particularly we're not just
testing our code right we're going to
test code the same way that the
engineers test code we're going to make
sure that we get the expected output
we're gonna test and make sure that it
can handle bad input and we're going to
test for all the edge cases we can think
of and as they come up we're going to
keep adding edge cases to our tests
but generally the software developers
don't have to do tests on data and
models and those things are critical for
the work that we do so we need to make
sure that we're testing those things as
well so we want to test that the data
that we're using is valid so we can
write tests just to look at our data set
and make sure it is what we think it is
we want to make sure that the types are
correct you know if you just do like
pandas read CSV you want to make sure
that the types that you're getting in
each of the columns are what they're
supposed to be and we want to make sure
that we're handling missing values
correctly and then for models when we
when we're talking about testing your
model so after you've created a model
you want to test that the format of the
model is correct you want to test that
it's producing the expected results the
reason that we were doing that is so
that we could benchmark it we were
saving our results every time and
comparing them over time seeing how our
performance was improving and you can
also monitor for model drift so you
can't just use one model forever you're
always going to be trying to improve it
right but if you do leave your model
unchanged but the data changes suddenly
the matchup between your model and your
data is gonna start to drift apart and
so if you've already saved these
benchmarks you can go back and compare
and see how that's happening okay I'm
gonna pull up my repo if anybody wants
to follow along you can just go ahead
and clone this my plan is that I will
pull it up and talk about a few things
and then try to do some live coding for
some tests so we'll see how that goes
but I already have the finished tests
saved in the repo so in case I mess
anything up it'll all be there and I'll
just pause for a second in case
anybody's gonna download that it's
pretty small if you're like me you're
probably gonna make a new virtual
environment there's nothing crazy in the
requirements it's just standard you know
pandas numpy SK learn
okay
cool so let me just clone my repo I'll
make a new virtual environment
and so then I'll just install my
requirements out text
and then the the easiest way to get this
working is if you have a setup I file
like I have and you can install this
repo and editable mode so to do that you
say pip install - II for editable dot
and so that's going to install the PI
data DC testing as a package that I can
then import okay so the code that I'm
going to be testing is just like a
simple example script there's a couple
kind of toy methods in here and we're
going to just kind of go through them
and write a couple tests so you can see
how simple PI test is to use so my first
method is one that just gets the time
and then gets a string to go at that
time and returns that so nothing special
since it doesn't have anything as input
all I'm really testing is making sure
that my output is valid so when they go
to my tests and we'll uh we'll move the
existing testify
okay so I'm starting a new file if you
have a sub folder in your project called
tests and you name all of the files in
that folder with the test prefix PI test
we'll find them automatically so you
don't have to do anything special I'm
going to be using some PI test features
so I'm going to import PI tests I'm
going to probably want to use some date
time stuff so let me import that okay
we'll start there
so just to write your first test all you
have to do is create a new method that
it has test as the prefix to its name so
we'll just call this one test get time
STR to match the name of the method
we're testing and so with PI tests we
normally want to use assertions and so
we're just going to make an assert
statement about some kind of equality so
my output I want to see a year month day
hour minute string so I'm just going to
write a test that says that so maybe
I'll say something like oh and let me
also import my package here so we're
gonna say from I did a DC testing import
experiment that's the name of this file
up here so maybe I can say something
like I'm gonna call this experiment get
time string method and I want to assert
that its output is what I think it
should be so I think it's going to be a
string generated by date time so let me
just generate a string from date time
okay so I'm going to get the time right
now and I'm going to give it a format
that I want it to make my string in so I
want my format to be here on day hour
minute and so that's my first test is
this output that I get from my method
going to give me the same result as this
date/time method does so I just saved
that file if you named everything
correctly with the test prefixes you
don't have to say anything except for PI
test and it runs when you look at the
output by default each test that you
have created is going to be represented
by a period if it passes so down here
I've got a little dot next to the file
name so I've got one test my one test
passed
and so one tat one passed in zero point
six three seconds alright cool so I can
keep writing some more tests so the next
method I have is called increment all it
does is it takes the input make sure
that it's a number as one two it so
let's write a test for that all right so
it's easy to think about the default
case the default case is I give it an
int I get back an int that's one bigger
so let me write a test for that if I
give it five I want to make sure that I
get six back but you know I'm not just
writing tests for my simple cases I'm
writing my test for every edge case that
I can think of so maybe I also want to
test like if I give it a negative number
I should probably get something like if
I give it a negative five I probably
want to get a negative four is my result
maybe I should probably test for like a
decimal so maybe I can say if I give it
a point five I would like to see one
point five is my output but if you look
at my code I also have some error
handling in there so if you pass in
something that's not a number
it should raise a type
so why don't I test something like that
too with PI tests you can test these
exceptions pretty easily you just use
with PI test dot raises and then you
tell it what type of error you're
expecting so I'm expecting a type error
and then you call whatever is going to
raise that error so we're gonna say
experiment increment and we'll give it a
string and maybe I also want to think
about like okay what how many what other
things could people do to try to throw
this off so maybe you could pass it a
none so let's make sure that it does a
type error gets passed it none all so
cool so these are like all of the
different inputs that I'm expecting that
I can think of off the top of my head as
I come up with more I'll add them to
this test case but for now we'll just go
with this so I'll just save this and
we'll run PI tests again and if I typed
in everything correctly I should get two
dots now cuz now I've got two test
methods running and they both passed
okay so so far this is just testing
basics nothing really interesting for
data scientists so now let's look at
things that are unique to data science
work for writing tests so the first
thing is that we probably work with
randomness more than most programmers
and developers do and so we have to kind
of think about how you can test for
things that are random so one thing that
we can do is if we have a way to measure
our output without being exact that's
going to be the best so I'm going to
have a method here that generates a
random normal distribution with a mean
of 100 and a standard deviation of 25
and it's going to give me a list of a
thousand numbers that are with that are
from that normal distribution so if I
want to test that that output is valid I
wanted a way to say if you look at these
thousand numbers are they probably from
a normal distribution right and that's
not something that you can just
look at and tell yes or no you could
make a plot of the distribution kind of
eyeball it and guess but there are
methods that'll do that and give you a
measure of how close it appears to be to
a normal distribution so let me go back
into my test file for this one I'm going
to need to import something new which is
from Sify stats I'm going to want to
import the normal test function okay so
now let's write a test for generate
random normal dist and so for this one
what I'm looking at is when I run this
function am I going to get a result that
is close to what I expect it to be so
the first thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to call the function
okay the results are it gives you two
variables as the output and I actually
don't remember what the first one is but
the second one is a p-value which
basically just tells you how likely it
is that this is from a normal
distribution and that's the one I want
so we're gonna say okay so now I have
generator generated numbers from my
random normal distribution I have put
those into the normal test and figured
out whether it thinks that this is
normal or not and now I'm going to
examine the p-value and see if it's what
I want so P values are values between 0
and 1 their probabilities the in this
instance the larger the p-value the more
likely it is that it came from a normal
distribution so that's what I want so a
good p value would be really small maybe
I could say something like greater than
0.01 so that that would mean there's
like at least a 99% chance that this is
truly normal so let's start with that
and see if we can pass or fail that one
okay so that one passed but I'm not
going to get the same result every time
and if I ran this a hundred times I
would expect that at least once I'm
gonna fail that test right but if I'm
saving these benchmarks as I go if I'm
logging my testing output if I did fail
that one time I could go back and look
at the results that I had previously and
see if that was reasonable or not
alright and so the last one I think I
probably have time for is I have a
method in here called the classify posts
pipeline and so this is really just a
basic SK learn example it uses SK learn
to
load some newsgroup data and then pass
all of that through a text processing
pipeline so it does it's got a
vectorizer tf-idf transformer SGD
classifier and then it runs a grid
search over that to try to find the best
parameters for each of those so this one
is going to have varying results because
if you look at the SGD classifier
that's stochastic gradient descent and
stochastic basically means it's going to
change so every time I run this I'm
going to get slightly different output
from this it's going to build a model
for me but the model is going to vary
from run to run so maybe the first time
I'm just gonna run it and see what my
results are so I can have a baseline and
then I'm going to write a test around
that so I'm gonna have to do a few more
imports here let's see probably wanted
to say mmm maybe you know maybe I have
everything I need so we're gonna say
test classify posts pipeline so for this
one first thing I want to do is run the
original method
save the results and now I'm going to
examine this grid search object and I'm
gonna look at the best score that I get
and I want it to be at least point 95
right and so the same as before I don't
actually know if I'm going to get that
score on my first run I probably won't
if I ran it a hundred times I probably
would get a score that was over 95 a
handful of those times right but my goal
here is not to have perfect results
every time it's just to set a baseline
and then be able to measure against that
baseline as I go so I'll run the test
and see if I pass or fail this one's
going to take a few seconds to crank
through because it's doing a grid search
so we'll just sit here patiently I said
some water all right so this time I
failed my test I wanted to get a score
of at least 95 and I probably didn't if
I scroll back up through the output
usually it's nice enough to show you
where you failed so it captures the
standard out and prints it to the screen
when you fail a test if you pass your
test you don't need to see your output
so it just suppresses it but by default
it'll print out the standard out when
you fail test so here's what I printed
out my best score this time was only 0.9
39 I needed it to be at least 95 to pass
the test so I could go back and just
lower the threshold or I could use a PI
test feature called X fail so X fail you
can just use it as a decorator and say
PI test mark X fail and what x fail is
is and it is an expected test failure so
I know that I don't have this model
working to my liking yet
I want this test to be here because I
know what the output is supposed to be
but I'm I'm not passing the test yet and
I'm gonna tell Pi test that it's not
passing by marking it as an X
and then an optional parameter here is I
can give it a reason justice maybe so I
don't forget so the reason is you know
baseline score was 0.9 39 right so when
I run the tests again it'll still fail
but now it'll be marked as an ex fail
and it won't count against me and it'll
let me know oh that's something I need
to keep working on so we'll just sit
here and wait well it plugs through
again cool so now instead of saying 4
fail or three pass 10:1 fail it says
three pass 1x failed and it'll still
give me an X right here in my output but
now I know that it that's supposed to
happen and it's not going to count it
against me if I run a coverage report or
if I view the output there I'll run an
HTML report in a minute it'll mark those
separately so I know the difference
there's a few more examples that I have
in the repo so if this is interesting to
you and you want to look at a few more
things some other features that PI test
has that are handy for doing data
science tests one is fixtures and and
fixtures are basically any time you want
to set something up and have it used
multiple times for lots of tests so if
you have a big data set you need to load
or if you need to make a connection to
something and you just want to run it
once instead of having to run it every
single test method you can just use the
PI test fixture decorator and then
whatever it returns will be something
you can use in all of your tests the way
that you use it is you just take that
and put it as an argument to your test
method all right so my PI test fixture
was called sales underscore records
I passed sales underscore records to
this test average method and it'll be
able to use that variable so we looked
at X fail in the code I didn't have one
that was called skip skip
exactly what you think it just doesn't
run that test exfil runs the test and
then tells you it failed but you knew it
skip just passes over that test until
you removed the mark another thing that
might be useful that I didn't have time
for in the talk is that you can compare
images and plots this is a feature
available in matplotlib so if you are
the kind of data scientist that produces
a lot of plots a lot of reports and you
want to make sure that your plots are
consistent or if you want to make sure
that it works on the same across
platforms or if you have somewhere that
you're going to be deploying your code
to and you want to make sure it runs the
same on that server as it does on your
local laptop you can generate test
images and then have your tests check
and see if the image is made on the
development or on the deployment
environment match those that you had on
your test environment and then like I
said benchmarking a model like I was
showing at the end there so that one is
is really not something that you would
expect the normal software engineers
that would need to do that would be
really valuable to us as data scientists
so another thing about PI test that
makes it really nice is there are lots
of configuration options for it and
their documentation is really great I
recommend that if you start writing
these tests you spend some time to look
through it
there's tons of features available so I
have a few that I included in my repo I
put all these in a shell script called
test SH just because you know these
things are easy to forget and this way
you can run the same same way every time
so these are the options that I have the
first one is it saves an HTML test
report I'll pull that up in a second
we'll look at it the self-contained HTML
flag just says put it all in one file
don't have like a CSS file and other
whatever other separate files the other
thing you can do is you can do coverage
reports and so this is something that
maybe you are not familiar with yet but
if you talk to a developer they are
definitely going to know what this means
this means that it tells whoever's
viewing your output how much of the code
you tested so if you have you know 100
lines of code and you test three of them
your test coverage is three percent
right so maybe it's not soo
valuable to you but it will be valuable
to whoever else is going to be looking
at your work and then report to missing
this is just a coverage report setting
and just tells it make a report to the
terminal and include the missing line
numbers so I know which lines weren't
tested yet and then the - RPP flag tells
it what test results to show you this
basically just shows you all of the test
results and then the very last argument
is where you're going to be testing so
on mine there's a folder called test so
I need to put that at the end of the
command so if I go back over here I have
all of that saved in a shell script I
have all that saved in a shell script
and it also checks and make sure that
logs directory exists before it does it
and so this way all I have to do is go
to the root directory of my project and
say run test is H and you'll do the same
thing every time so I can do that now
so it doesn't really look any different
it still just runs the tests but the one
thing that this does that the other one
didn't is now because I have the HTML
flag it'll create an HTML output file
and so when it finishes doing the grid
search one last time I'll go ahead and
pull up that HTML file and we'll see
what it looks like okay so I've got my
test logs we'll open up that HTML report
and so this is just the default
configuration for pi tests HTML reports
you can configure all of this output and
you can add in extra information you can
if you can add in special tags for only
things that fail only things that X fail
you can add in if you want to like
present what the current variable is you
can add that in here too but basically
if you fail or X fail it gives you a
report showing you all of the things
about why you failed and if you passed
it doesn't really tell you much of
anything it just says I passed and
here's the test message test method that
passed oh and so this is just one of the
things that I like it's a nice pretty
way to view results and if you save
these HTML files as you go you know you
can use this to look back and compare
your results over time alright so that's
the end of my presentation just my
conclusion PI sites is really easy to
use you can get started right away so go
ahead and start now for whatever it is
that you're working on write some tests
and see how you like it it'll earn you
the trust and respect of your peers and
you can use it even if your code is
castex so if you get different results
every time you can still write tests for
that so questions
[Applause]
[Music]
what would you like me to talk about
[Music]
okay so mocking when referred to in
testing basically means you don't want
to have to do something for real so you
don't want to connect to a real database
you don't want to load a real data file
you want to do something fake that's not
gonna take as long or it's not going to
make external connections and so the
question is when you have a huge data
frame and you want to do tests on it
should you test on the real huge data
frame with millions and millions of rows
or should you make a mock of it and
that's really you know I can't answer
that question because that's going to
depend on the circumstances of your in
you know if you are in a
mission-critical environment and it's
important to make sure that every single
thing is valid then you should use your
whole data frame right if you need to
make sure that there is not a single man
in that whole thing then go ahead and
use that but for me I don't want tests
to run a long time you know if I have a
test that takes half an hour to run I'm
not going to run it very often right so
I would say mock it down to a reasonable
size so that you can run all of your
tests in what you think is a reasonable
time thank you
thank you for your talk very interesting
how do we convince people to write tests
I find it very challenging to convince
anyone to invest in them including
senior people just quickly do it you
know we'll get to testing later it never
happens is there are there any
statistics for example showing that good
tests help you over the long run oh yeah
there I mean this is this is something
that is not unique to data science this
is something that is you know been
consistent throughout the history of
data science people don't like writing
tests because it's not easy it takes
time away from doing what you consider
to be your real work it doesn't get you
like fame and fortune and you know
depending on on what kind of manager you
have some people don't see it as being
valid output right like if they're
measuring how much code you're producing
they might not consider your tests to be
part of that but there is a plethora of
research going back decades that says
that testing is great and the more tests
you write the better there's there's
basically no limit to how much it will
improve your work it's going to increase
your efficiency it's going to save your
company money over time all of that data
is definitely out there so I guess if we
wanted to sort a lot to learn more about
how as a research engineer to do better
testing do this kind of more integrated
kind of testing are there any kind of
like books or people we should follow
like I don't know about books or people
you should follow but one thing that I
think would be a really great resource
if you are like just getting started is
included in my readme at the bottom of
my readme there's a couple of resources
and this data science testing tutorial
is a really excellent repo that shows
some of the things that I showed but a
lot more as well and so I would say
start there there are books about
there's a book about test-driven
development for data science
that I know it was really valuable so hi
I just wanted to make a comment about
the convincing people to write tests
because this is something that seems to
come up a lot I've I guess been very
fortunate to work in multiple places
with TDD as like something they practice
and I can't tell you the amount of times
I've said oh man I'm so glad that test
was there when I was working on another
piece of code that somehow affected the
logic of another piece of code and the
time like you savings and debugging is
like it should speak for itself
and I think what is hard for most people
is to get started so if you want to be
that person you have to set it up for
them and for every like pull review or
sorry pull request or whatever you could
be like hey where are the tests and
don't accept it or something like it
just it's the seed you plant and it
grows and it's so helpful yeah thank you
so much for anecdote that's so one of
the great things about tests is once
you've written a test it doesn't change
so you can change your code with the
test won't and if your code no longer
does what it's supposed to Europe you'll
find out okay we're out of time so let's
think David again
[Music]